مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض وهذه ابرز وعناوين اليوم
الجيش المصري يؤكد مقتل عنصر امن باطلاق
نار بعد اجتيازه حاجزا اسرائيليا اثناء
مطارده مهرب مخدرات
وزير خارجيه السعوديه وايران يلتقيان على
هامش اجتماع مجموعه بريكس في جنوب افريقيا
السعوديه تبدا حصر اصحاب الاجور المتجاوزه
للسقف الاعلى وتعتمد عقدا حكوميا موحدا
للعمل
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه ايضا
العربيه توثق قصه شفاء الطفلين مفلح وفي
الحامله الفشل الكلوي بعد اجراء عمليتي
زراعه الكلى
ايات التراث السعوديه تعلن اكتشاف الحكوم
كسادسي اقدم نقش عربي مبكر في منطقه نجران
حياكم الله اعلنا الجيش المصري عن مقتل
عنصر امن باطلاق نار اثناء مطاردته مهربي
مخدرات على الحدود مع اسرائيل وقال
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش المصري ان عنصر
الامن اضطر لاختراق الحاجز الاسرائيلي
اثناء عمليه مطارده قبل ان يفارق الحياه
خلال تبادل لاطلاق النار
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه جنود
واصابه اخر في حادث امني على الحدود مع
مصر كما اعلن تحيد مطلق النار واوضح بيان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان من وصفه بالمخرب هو
شرطي مصري مشيرا الى ان التحقيق في الحادث
يتم بتعاون كامل ووثيق مع الجيش المصري
واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قوه يتواصل
اعمال التمشيط في المنطقه تاكدي من عدم
وجود مخربين اخرين
طلب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان حادثه
اطلاق النار على الحدود مع مصر انتهى
بنتائج وخيمه وفي تغريده على تويتر اضاف
جالنت ان الجنود الاسرائيليين ادوا مهامهم
بتفان وكده ان التحقيقات ستجرى بدقه وان
قاده الجيش يواصلون اداء مهامهم بعزم
ومثابره
كشفت مصادر العربيه عن اتصالات مصريه
اسرائيليه قد تمت بهدف عقد اجتماع امني
عاجل بشان اطلاق النار على الحدود بين
البلدين اضافت مصادر العربيه الى انه تم
تشكيل لجنه مصريه اسرائيليه بشان حادث
اطلاق النار على الحدود ومنع تكراره
ومعنا من معبر نتسانا مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاصي لان مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض
هل انتهت هذه الحادثه بشكل كامل اغرق هذا
الملف
اهلا بك الحدث الامري هو يعني بدا منذ فجر
اليوم منذ تمام الساعه الرابعه فجرا
تقريبا ويستمر حتى هذه اللحظه لم ينتهي
حتى الان هناك يعني تعزيزات امنيه
وتعزيزات عسكريه يعني تتواجد في المنطقه
التي تم بها اطلاق النار الذي ادى الى
مقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين وايضا مقتل
جندي مصري من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه التي
تدعي بان جندي مصري هو قام بالتسلل الى
اراضي اسرائيليه وقام باطلاق النار على
جنود اسرائيليين منهم مجنده وجنديين
اسرائيليين فعليا ما ادى الى مقتلهم ولكن
تعزيزات امنيه تم ارسالها من قبل القوات
والاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه الى المنطقه
لتمشيط المنطقه بشكل كامل والتاكد انه لا
يوجد هناك اي اشخاص مسلحين اخرين يعني
يشكلون تهديدا وخطرا امنيا على اسرائيل
اين تحدث ان الطائرات ايضا العسكريه
للمراقبه ما زالت تحلق فوق المنطقه
والتمشيط تم بعث اي فعليا قوات خاصه من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي الذين يقومون يعني
التفتيش المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه هل تم
اغلاق هذا المعبر معبر نتسانه ولو مؤقتا
لاي اجراءات امنيه او عسكريه او تمشيط
ايضا كذلك لنا
صحيح المعبر هو مغلق كما ترى من خلفه هو
مغلق بشكل تام وكامل ايضا المنطقه التي تم
بها اطلاق النار تم اغلاقها واعلانها
منطقه عسكريه مغلقه تواجد مكثف من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا من من حيث
تواجدنا في القدس من القدس الى هذه
المنطقه في الجنوب كان هناك في الطريق
ايضا حواجز قامت القوات الاسرائيليه بنصب
عدد من الحواجز واغلاق عدد من الشوارع
المؤديه الى المنطقه الحدوديه اين نتحدث
ان حاله التاهب ما زالت مستمره من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه عمليات ايضا كذلك
التنشيط الجوي كنا نتابعها يعني على
الهواء مباشره قبل اكثر من ساعه هل لا
زالت تنشط المروحيات الاسرائيليه في
عملياتها التمشيطيه الجويه حتى هذه اللحظه
صحيح حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت الطائرات
تحلق لان فعليا العمليه وعمليه التمشيط لم
تنتهي حتى الان كان هناك قبل قليل ايضا
جلسه لتقييم الاوضاع لم يتم ذكر تفاصيل
كثيره بشان هذا هذه الجلسه ولكن حتى الان
على ما يبدو ان تفاصيل الموضوع لم يعني لن
تكون واضحه حتى الان ننتظر ايضا البيانات
من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي لتاكيد ما هذه ما
هي الروايه لان الروايه ايضا الاسرائيليه
هي متناقضه بالنسبه للبيان المصري
والاعلام المصري يعني
بنقطه مهمه كنت اود السؤال ايضا عنها لانا
يعني هل هناك فعلا من تناقض او اختلاف ما
بين الروايتين المصريه والاسرائيليه وباي
شكل حتى يفهم المشاهد نوعيه هذا التناقض
او النقاط التي فيها اختلاف بين البيانيين
صحيح على ما يبدو ان هناك نقاط يختلف
عليها الجانب الاسرائيلي والجانب المصري
حاليا حسب البيانات الصادره عن الجانب
الاسرائيلي وايضا عن الجانب المصري ناطق
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي والناطق باسم
الشرطه الاسرائيليه قبل قليل كان هناك
اعلان صادر منهم قد اكدوا بان هناك يعني
مسلح قالوا بانه هو مصري وينتمي الى الجيش
المصري كان بلباس ايضا الجيش المصري قد
تسلل الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه وقام باطلاق
النار على مجنده واسرائيليه وايضا جنديين
اسرائيليين ما ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين اما الروايه المصريه تقول بان
الجندي المصري كان يحاول فعليا ملاحقه احد
المهربين مهربين المخدرات على ما يبدو
وكان يعني يحاول المحافظه على الامن
وقامت القوات الاسرائيليه بقتله على ما
يبدو بالخطا
اشكرك جزيلا الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل التي وفيتينا بها من معبر
نيتسانا مراسله العربيه لانك الغاز شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا لازمنا نتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذا الخبر
العاجل اسفل الشاشه اعلام اسرائيلي عن
مسؤول يقول بان حادث اطلاق النار على
الحدود مع مصر فردي ولا
نيه
للتصعيد اذا اعلان اسرائيلي مسؤول يقول
بان حادث اطلاق النار على الحدود مع مصر
والذي تابعناه منذ اليوم هذه الحادثه التي
وقعت في
الرابعه والنصف فجرا حسب ما نقل مراسل
العربيه في وقت سابق بان هذه الحادثه على
الحدود مع مصر هي فرديه ولا
نيه للتصعيد
التقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان مع نظيره الايراني حسين امير عبد
اللهيان على هامش الاجتماع الوزاري
لاصدقائي مجموعه بريكس بمدينه كيب تاون في
جنوب افريقيا اوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه في
بيان انه جرى خلال اللقاء بحث سبولي تعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه في العديد من المجالات
بالاضافه الى متابعه خطوات تنفيذ اتفاق
البلدين
الموقعي في بكين بما فيه تكثيف العمل
الثنائي لضمان تحقيق الامن والسلم
الدوليين وعبر الجانبان خلال اللقاء عن
تطلعهما الى تكثيف اللقاءات التشاوريه
وبحث سبل التعاون لتحقيق المزيد من الافاق
الايجابيه للعلاقات الثنائيه والمتعدده
الاطراف بما يخدم مصالح البلدين والشعبين
هنا في الاستديو الكاتب الصحفي جاسر جاسر
حياك الله جاسر الرابعه من الرياض لقاء
جديد بين الوزيرين السعودي والايراني ما
الذي يمكن قراءته في تسريع وتيره هذا
الاتفاق بين البلدين وتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه
من الطرفين
اعتقد انه واضح المسار يعني يمكن لو طرحنا
الاسئله في عشره مارس ايام اتوقع الاتفاق
كان في هناك اسئله قلقه بشكل كبير اليوم
لا نتحدث عن خطوات عمليه خزال القلق
درجه تفاؤل ارتفعت بشكل كبير على التفاصيل
يعني موضوع السفارات انتهت في الاجراءات
التنفيذيه لم يعد هناك مشكله عيون السفراء
تم يعني فادخلنا فيه المرحله حتى في
الاطار الزمني المتفق عليه ولعل في نقاط
مهمه كثره اللقاءات بين الامير فيصل
والوزير الخارجيه الايراني بشكل متكرر وفي
كل المناسبات المختلفه حجم ممنوع
التصريحات الايرانيه المتواليه يعني بشكل
يوم تصريحات عن تطور لا ننسى ايضا اللقاء
الاقتصادي في بنك الاسره في اجتماع البنك
الاسلامي للتنميه وزير الاقتصاد الايراني
والتقى مع الوزير الجدعان ووزير الماليه
السعودي وبالتالي يعني هناك خطوات عمليه
ندخل احنا ندخل الان بشكل عملي وبشكل اكثر
في المج الاقتصادي الاساسي والاتفاقات
الاقتصاديه وفود اقتصاديه من البلدين
اصبحت تذهب وتاتي هذا التسريع يعني
العلامات ودائما الاقتصاد هو المحكه
الاساسي للاتفاقات السياسيه
بما انه بدات عمليه تدفق للمشروعات حتى
المستوى النظري بسبب في فرق معين انه
ايران دوله مجهوله مغلقه يعني انت تستثمر
مثلا على سبيل في ماليزيا واضح المشاريع
اليوم ايران دوله مغلقه بسبب العقوبات
وبسبب اقتصادات العلاقه في مرحله استكشاف
لكن روايه كبيره والتداخل بهذا المساله
الاخير ايضا بين وزيرين مع الامير فيصل
طال عمرك ايضا مؤشر مهم
مؤشر مهم اقتصادي وسياسي في التحول وحضور
المملكه ايضا له دلالات معينه قد تكون لها
نتائج مستقبليه فيها بس جاسم منذ الاتفاق
الذي وقع في العاشر من مارس الماضي في
بكين حتى اللحظه كيف يمكن ان ننظر
لخطوات تنفيذ هذا الات الوتيره هل هي اتت
بشكل متسق مع اهميه هذا
الاتفاقا بوتيره سريعه وهل نفذت بشكلها
الكامل حسب متابعتك ومطابعتك انا اتاكد
انه الخطوات اكثر والثقه بين الطرفين اعلى
والتواصل اكثر استمراريه واكثر تنوعا
وتحددا لم يعد مقتصرا على اللقاءات بين
وزيري الخارجيه والتفاهمات اصبح دخول في
خطوات وهذا مؤشر فعلا ايجابي لم يكن متوقع
حجم الشكوك المرتفع جدا تراجع بدرجه كبيره
تراجب التالي ايضا بالعكس ارتفعت التفاؤل
بالدخول في الخطوات التنفيذيه المختلفه
على المستوى واحنا جدا انعكاسات ترى
مختلفه انعكاسات هذه لنقل بهذا الاتفاق
السعودي للايراني تحديدا الامن بدرجه
كبيره في اغلاق الملف اليمني طبعا نسمع
على سبيل المثال الكلام من الايرانيين
اليوم يتحدثون عن فكره انشاء تكتل بحري
وفرقه بحريه امنيه هذه خطوه اذا تحققت
يعني ايضا السعوديات اطمئن تماما
وانه تغير ايضا لكن خطوه طبعا من اجل تتم
تتطلب كثير من المعايير والاتفاقات
والتفاصيل الفنيه
هناك جانب مهم سعوديه دوله لا تتكلم كثيرا
يعني لو لو جمعنا في الفتره الماضيه من
عشره اليوم لنا كاد نجد تصريحات سعوديه
كثيره عن طريق لكن نجد خطوات عمليه نجد
تذهب نجد لقاءات نجد اجراءات تنفذ نجد
استجابات معينه وبالتالي خطه عمل وليست هي
المساله يعني لم يكن توقع على اتفاق من
الاساس عاطفيا وبالتالي النتائج ليست
عاطفيه نتائج محسوبه وتقوم على المدى
الهدف الاساسي تحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه
ان نكون شركاء هل تحقق ذلك بمعنى
الملامح الاولى تقول يعني نسال هل هل هذا
الاتفاق وما جرى ايضا بعده من لقاءات ما
جرى ايضا بعده ربما من تصريحات من تقارب
اعاده السفراء ايضا كذلك او تسميه السفراء
القنصليات كيف انعكست على حاله السلم
والام الاقليميه اليوم حتى الان هل يمكن
ملاحظتها او التغيير فيها كذلك طبعا بعض
التفاصيل تحتاج الى وقت لكن نعم يمكن
احفظها حاله الاستقرار في اليمن طبعا هذا
جانب اساسي العمل مشترك نحن نتكلم ايضا
على جوانب من المشكله ليست متصله بالاتفاق
بشكل مباشر لكن مثلا الميليشيات في العراق
في سوريا في بناء اعاده الوضع الاستقرار
في العالم العربي نجد انه مثلا العراقيين
انهم يعني يعملون على ان يكون ممرات
ترانزيت للتجاره الانفتاح في الجرس هذه
خطوات طبعا لا تتم بسرعه لكن لنقل انه
البصمات التي تجري او الاجراءات اللي يتم
اتخاذها هناك لنقل نوع من الشغف او الرغبه
الكبيره في الاستثمار المشترك ايران تدعو
السعوديه لبناء الفنادق تدعو الى المشاركه
في الغاز والنفط اليوم مثلا في الاستثمار
فيها تحاول ان تستفيد من المهارات
والخبرات السعوديه في هذا الجانب ان تتحول
ايضا البضائع الايرانيه هذه الاجراءات
تمشي وبالتالي هذا يرتد بشكل اساسي ولم
يكن بشكل اتفاق الطرفين المملكه وايران
قوه الكريان والجرين المهمين ايضا
والتقارب في المسار نحن نقول هناك شبكه
معقده من المصالح والارتباطات لا يمكن حتى
لا نكون مندفعين او عاطفيين لكن هي تحسب
بمعايير محدده وبالتالي كيف يمكن بشكل
اساسي ان نعمل سويا فيما يحقق مسرحتنا
ويحقق اليوم هناك
عطفا على ما ذكرت سيد جاسر انه في اتجاه
الى التنميه اتجاه الى الاقتصاد يعني
بكافه اشكاله التبادلات التجاريه وغيرها
وبان المنطقه اليوم اصبحت تعيش حاله ربما
تنمويه مزدهره اكثر بما يحقق هذا
المشروع السعودي تحديدا لولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الذي ذكر في
اكثر من مره بان الشرق الاوسط سيتحول يوما
ما الى اوروبا جديده هل الظروف مواتيه
اليوم لهذا الامر ام لا نحتاج الى وقت
نحتاج الى بناء ثقه نحتاج الى تواصل اكثر
انا بقول بس مبادره الامير مبادره الشرق
الاوسط الاخضر اللي طلعها الامير محمد بن
سلمان هي مبادره في شكل العام بي
في شكلها الظاهري او الخاتم لكن كيف ممكن
تكون تتحقق بهذا المساله اذا لم تكون هناك
تنميه وناقص استقرار وتحاون كيف يمكن فرد
هذه المظله الخضراء مثلا من لم يكن هناك
البلدان تعيش حاله من الرخاء والاستقرار
والعمل المشترك نعم هناك نجد اليوم مثلا
التحول مع سوريا ايجابي والعمل على عدد
سوريا واعاده تنميتها وادخلها في المجموعه
العربيه بشكل كامل والتخلص من الرواسب
والقضاء على الجماعات الارهابيه وركض نعم
نجد ان هناك فعلا ليست هناك مشروع قوي تم
العمل عليه
سنواجه مطبات محتمل بعض الصعوبات تتعلق في
نقاط لكن المظله الكبرى نعم ستستمر لانها
تقوم على معطيات واضحه ومحدده وتكون على
خطوات واجراءات وتعامل دقيق نحن لا نتفاهم
على المساله يعني من السهل البيانات لكن
من الصعب اتخاذ الاجراءات فاذا وصلنا كلما
تعمقنا في الجانب الاقتصادي دخلنا في
المرحله الاكيده والواثقه والمطمئنه لانه
هذه ارهانات برؤوس اموال هذه دهانات
استثماريه لا تغامر بشكل ايضا متهور ما لم
يكن هناك ضمانات ويقين اننا نسير في
المسار الصح اشكرك جزيل الشكر في
الاستوديو الكاتب الصحيحه في جاسر الجاسر
شكرا سيد جاسر
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير
انتوني بلينكل سيتوجه في السادس من يونيو
الى السعوديه لعقد اجتماعات اقتصاديه
وامنيه واوضحت خارجيه الامريكيه في بيان
ان بلينكن سيبحث خلال محادثاته مع
المسؤولين السعوديين التعاون الاستراتيجيه
بين البلدين في القضايا الاقليميه
والثنائيه
كشف الهلال الاحمر السوداني انه مع احتدام
حده الصراع في البلاد تم دفن 180 شخصا
مجهولي الهويه في الخرطوم ودارفور واكذا
الهلال الاحمر السوداني ان متطوعي الهلال
بدعم من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
وجدوا صعوبه كبيره بالتنقل في الشوارع
لالتقاط الجثث بسبب القيود الامنيه وقتل
اكثر من 1800 شخص منذ بدايه الصراع في
الخامس عشر من ابريل ابقى اخر الارقام
التي صدرت حديثا فيما بلغ عدد المفقودين
200 وثلاثه وثمانين شخصا
وفي اخر تطورات المعارك اطلق للجيش
السوداني قذائف مدفعيه بشكل كثيف في ام
درمان في عده اتجاهات فيما دلعت اشتباكات
وسمع دوي انفجارات في اماكن استراتيجيه في
الخرطوم القصف المدفعي تركز في جنوب
العاصمه السودانيه بينما دارت اشتباكات في
شرقها فيما اعلن الجيش استقدام تعزيزات
عسكريه وطال القصف المدفعي ايضا منطقه
قريبه من مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في
ضاحيه ام درمان وفق وكاله فرانسبريس
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
الحج والعمره تكشف للعربيه تخصيص سته عشره
شركه لحجاج الخارج و180 لحجاج الداخل
حياكم الله من جديد بعد موافقه مجلس
الوزراء السعودي على قواعد المنظمه لشؤون
العاملين في الاجهزه العامه نشرت جريده ام
القرى الرسميه احكام العاملين في الدوله
وتعويضات والتي منها اعداد نموذج عقد عمل
موحد للموظفين
السعوديه جريده ام القرى تنشر قواعد
واحكام شؤون العاملين في الدوله تضمنت
الاحكام ما يلي مراجعه سيعلم الرواتب
الوظيفيه بما يتوافق مع اسقف الاجور
المعتمده ومراجعه لوائح البدلات والمكافات
والمزايا الموظفين كما تضمرت حصر حالات
اصحاب الاجور والمزايا الماليه المتجاوزه
للسقوف القصوى ووضع معايير تصميم سلم
الرواتب الوظيفي واعداد السقوف الالزاميه
القصوى لاجور الفئات الوظيفيه اضافه الى
اعداد نموذج عقد العمايل الموحد واعداد
خطه للقوى العامله
واعداد خطه للتوظيف تشمال اعداد الوظائف
واسمائها ومستوياتها المراد التوظيف عليها
سنويا
ينظم الي هنا في الاستوديو عضما لسداره
الجمعيه السعوديه للاداره بجامعه الملك
سعود الدكتور خليل ذيابي دكتور خليل حياك
الله معيشه الرابعه من الرياضيين يحييك
واحيي الساده المشاهير اهلا وسهلا فيك ما
الذي تعنيه هذه القواعد الجديده ومن
المشمول بها ايضا
اولا مرحبا بك استاذ نايف القواعد
لصدرت من مجلس الوزراء الاسبوع الماضي
وقرت في الصحيفه الرسميه امس في جريده ام
القرى هي مشمول فيها موظفين في الماده
الثالثه ذكرت فيها مشمول فيها موظفين
التابعين لوزاره الموارد البشريه اي اللي
يعملون على نظام العمل والعمال بمعنى انه
لا يتعلق بموظفين الخدمه المدنيه حاليا لا
يتعلق بموظفي الخدمه المدنيه احنا في
السابق
اقرت الدوله
الغاء وزاره الخدمه المدنيه وضمها الى
وزاره الموارد البشريه واصبحت هنا اصبح
هناك نظامين نظام الخدمه المدنيه ونظام
الموارد البشريه ومن ثم قره برامج الخصخصه
والتحول اي الخصخصه والتحول في المنظمات
او الوزارات بشكل عام راح يكون هناك
خصخصه من نظام الخدمه المدنيه الى نظام
العمل والعمال في الحالي لا يشمل الموظفين
المدنيه لكن مستقبلا عندما تتحول الجهات
والوزارات الى خصخصه راح موظفين للخدمه
المدنيه يشملهم هذا النظام هي الان تعني
هذه القواعد مراجحه مراجعه لوائح البدلات
صحيح والمكافات والمزايا للموظفين بمعنى
سيعاد النظر في فيما هو موجود الان وليس
في شيء يضاف اليها صحيح الان في الماده
الرابعه ذكرت في الماده الرابعه ذكرت انه
انه يعاد انظمه البدلات لجميع الرواتب
والبدلات والمزايا لجميع الموظفين
الخاضعين لنظام العمل والعمال اي نظام اي
نظام وزاره الموارد البشريه شبه الحكومه
الشبه الحكوميه نعم باستثناء ست حالات
وذكرت في القرار الحاله الاولى
وكلاء الوزارات
والمساعدين لوكلاء الوزارات باستثناء
المزايا الماليه باستثناء المجال الماليه
اثنين بندل كفاءات المتميزه بنت التعاقد
على كفاءه المتميزه قبل سنه تقريبا صدر
قرار مجلس الوزراء باعاده ترتيب بند
الكفاءات المتميزه
مجلس من وزاره الموارد البشريه ومجلس من
وزاره الماليه
لاعاده النظر في الهياء في
في في سلالم الرواتب وانها ما تتجاوز الحد
الاعلى للمنظمات
وراح يكون اعاده ترتيب احنا استاذ نايف في
علم الموارد البشريه هناك خمس تصنيفات
رئيسيه اولا لما تنشئ منظمه لابد انك تصمم
تصمم ماذا تصمم الوظيفه ومن ثم تحلل
الوظيفه من ثم تحلل الوظيفه ومن ثم توصف
الوظيفه ما هي اعمالها ادوار هذه الوظيفه
ومن ثم
تصنيف الوظائف حسب التضييع مثلا وظائف
القطاع الصحي وظائف القطاع التعليمي ومن
ثم تقييم الوظائف تقيمها هذا القرار بشكل
عام تقيم الوظائف تعطيها قيمه كم تستحق
هذه الوظيفه مرتب هذه اعاده
القرار ايضا جاء فيه
لو كان موسع فانا احاول اني اخذك قرار جدا
موسعه في اعداد نموذج عقد العمل الموحد
صحيح وش اللي يعني العقد العمل مثل العقود
القائمه في الشركات العقد العمل انه تكتب
اساسيات رئيسيه بالخطوط العريضه في عقود
العمل موحده على جميع الوزارات بمن ضمنها
الخطوط العريضه وضع الرواتب والبدلات
والمزايا ايضا من الخطوط العريضه وضع
الاجازات واستحقاقات الموظف
ايضا وضع ساعات العمل للموظف في الخطوط
العريضه وتكون موحده على جميع الوزارات
في الرواتب بين الموظفين
بالتاكيد راح يكون هناك تنظيم كامل لجميع
الوزارات حتى لا يكون هناك تفاوت باستثناء
السته النقاط اللي ذكرتها بالماده الرابعه
راح يكون هناك تنظيم على جميع الوزارات
وفق سلالم وظيفيه محدده جزيل الشكر انا ما
اتوقع عندي كثير من الوقت مستمتع بالحديث
الله
اكيد يعني شكرا جزيلا لعضو مجلس اداره
الجمعيه السعوديه للاداره والجامعه الملك
سعود الدكتور خليل ذيابي الله يعطيك الله
يحييك
كشفت وزاره الحج والعمره للعربيه عن تخصيص
سته عشره شركه لحجاج الخارج وقربه 180
شركه لخدمه حجاج الداخل بالاضافه الى
تخصيص ثلاثه ملايين متر مربع بمشعر منى
وقرابه 12 مليون متر مربع بمشعل عرفه
لاستقبال الحجاج الذي سوف يصل عددهم الى
اثنين مليون حاج منهم 210 الاف حاج من
الداخل بين مواطنين ومقيمين
ومن مشاعري منها يلتحق بنا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي سلطان مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابع من الرياض وحشنا في
الرابع اول شيء من زمان عنك
وكلمني اليوم انت موجود في مشعر امنا
الاستعدادات لحد هذا العام ايضا كذلك وعن
شركات الحجاج من الداخل والخارج ايضا كيف
يمكن وصف الصوره بشكل كامل
اهلا بكم اهلا بكافه مشاهدي نشره الرابعه
بالفعل ايام محدوده تفصلنا عن بدء موسم
الحجل نشاهد امامنا استعدادات كبيره هنا
في مشارار في مشعر منها وكذلك في مشاعر
عرفه ومزدلفه استعدادا لبدء موسم الحج
نتحدث عن استعدادات كبيره لوزاره الحج
والعمره وكذلك كافه القطاعات العامله في
موسم الحج وشركات الحج والعمره لتجهيز هذه
المخيمات والانتهاء من اعمال الصيانه
والترميم واكتمال كافه المشاريع البنيه
التحتيه للتعامل مع اعداد مليونيه فهذا
الموسم والعوده للاعداد الى مقبل جائحه
فيروس كورونا نتحدث عن اعداد تصل الى
اثنين مليون احاج منهم 200 وعشره الاف حاج
من الداخل بين مواطنين ومقيمين نتحدث هنا
في مشعر مينا يتم العمل بكامل الطاقه
الاستيعابين التحدث عن اكثر من ثلاثه
مليون متر مربع هي مخصصه الحجاج هذا
الموسم هنالك في عرفه نتحدث على اكثر من
12 مليون متر مربع استعدادات كبيره من
ضمنها وبيقدمتها اعمال البنيه التحتيه
هناك في مشعر عرفه نتحدث على اكتمال
البنيه التحتيه الخاصه باعمال التمديدات
الكهربائيه فيما يتعلق بمخيمات قمنا باداء
او عمل جوله خلال الساعات الماضيه هنا في
مشعر مينا استعدادات كبيره تبقى فقط
اللمسات النهائيه على هذه المخيمات هنالك
جولات رقابيه كبيره تعمل عليها وزاره الحج
والعمره برفقه القطاعات العامله للتاكد من
جهوزيه هذه المخيمات لاستقبال الحجاج
لموسم حج هذا العام نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره
فيما يتعلق بالفرضيات تم عمل فرضيتين خلال
الايام الماضيه يوم يوم الاثنين نتحدث على
فرضيه كبيره جدا سوف تقوم بها وزاره الحج
وكافه القطاعات العامله في كافه المشاعر
المقدسه للتاكد من جاهزيه هذه المشاعر
وهذه المخيمات وكافه المرافق الخدميه
لخدمه الحجاج قبل موت قبل بدء موسم الحج
وهي سوف تكون الفرضيه الثالثه والاخيره
لموسم حج هذا العام نتحدث عن استعدادات
كبيره لم تشهدها مواسم الحج الماضيه
للتعامل مع هذه الارقام الكبيره تحدث على
وجود اكثر من 24 الف حافله سوف تقوم
بعمليه النقل التردد لنتحدث قبل قليل كان
هناك عمليات تجريبيه لقطار المشاعر
المقدسه للتاكل
عمليات الصيانه ايضا هناك استعدادات كبيره
فيما يتعلق بتصاريح الحج والتاكد من
جوزيات شركات الحج الداخل والخارجي نتحدث
عن وجود او وصول 160 الف حاج من الخارج
وصلوا حتى هذه هي اللحظه عبر مطار الملك
عبد العزيز الدولي بجده وعبر ميناء جده
الاسلامي وكذلك عبر مطار المدينه المنوره
يتحدث عن اكثر من 70 الف حاج من الخارج
قاموا باداءه طواف القدوم هنا في هنا في
مكه المكرمه
نتحدث عن جولات رقابيه لامانه العاصمه
المقدسه قامت بتسخير قرابه 22 الف موظف
وموظفه بنتحدث عن اعداد كبيره من الاليات
للتاكد من عملها في موسم الحج هذا العام
ايضا وزاره الشؤون الاسلاميه قامت بجولات
رقابيه على المساجد والتاكد من سلامتها
وعمليه تشغيلها لبدء موسم الحج فيما يتعلق
بكافه القطاعات الحكوميه العامله هنا في
موسم الحج تقوم بكامل ادوارها وبكافه
ادوارها للتاكد من ان يكون موسم حج السالم
وامن فيما يتعلق بوزاره الصحه نشاهد عربات
الاسعاف متواجده من وقت مبكرا ايضا
الكوادر الصحيه والفرقه الرقابيه
المتواجده في المستشفيات لتجهيزها والتاكد
من عمليه تشغيلها والعدد كبير من الادوار
تعمل عليها جهه الحكوميه استعدادا لبدء
موسم حج اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات كل هذه التفاصيل التي نقلتها
لنا من مشعر منى مراسل العربيه السلطان
السليمه شكرا جزيلا يا سلطان
شدد وزير الشؤون الاسلاميه والدعوه
والارشاد الدكتور عبد اللطيف بن عبد
العزيز ال الشيخ على عدم السماح لاحد ان
يتدخل في موضوع الدعاه المتراجعين عن
افكارهم وفتواهم التي فتواهم التي غرروا
بها الناس على حد وصفه واكد وزير الشؤون
الاسلاميه على انه لابد من هؤلاء الدعاه
المتراجعين عن افكارهم
فتواهم ان يكونوا صادقين وان يعلنوا عن
تراجعهم على الملل مشيرا الى انه لن يتم
قبول التراجعات الورقيه بل عليهم ان
يتبراوا بشكل علني من الاشرطه التي بثوا
من خلالها افكارهم وفتاواهم
تمثل عمليات زراعه الكلى للاطفال المصابين
بالفشل الكلوي الحل الامثل للحد من
المضاعفات التي تحدث مع الفشل الكلوي حيث
تاتي اهميتها في تحسين نمو الصحي والغذائي
للطفل ومواصله حياته بشكل طبيعي المزيد مع
مفلح وفلحه مصاباني بالفشل الكلوي منذ
ولادتهما امبيان نحو 12 عاما في غسيل
الكلى الدموي والبروتيني لتنتهي فصولهما
بعد اجراء عمليات زراعه الكلى
ضم العمليه
مما يعني
ما في ما اشرب كثير
واكل يعني مو كثير والكاكاو ممنوع ومدرسه
ما اروح
وانا صار لي 11 سنه ونقصد وشو اسمه وانا
شو اسمه 13 ساعه مربوط بالغسيل والحين
الحمد لله عشره مويه كثير
واكيد كثير يعني اشياء اللي ممنوع بالاول
الحين مو ممنوعه
[موسيقى]
الطفل بعد الزراعه الهدف من الزراعه انه
يعيش حياه طبيعيه الطفل يرجع للمدرسه
ما يكون فيه ممنوعات على قد ما كانت اول
عبد الله تنقل ما بين مدينتي نجران وابهى
جنوب السعوديه لاربع سنوات بسبب الغسيل
الكلوي لطفليه يوسف وبشرى قبل ان ينتقل
بهما الى مستشفى الملك فهد التخصصي
بالدمام لاجراء عمليات زراعه الكلى اليوم
تستطيع بشرى ان تحتضن والدها بعد ان كانت
عجزه عن الحركه سابقا كانت معنا يعني
اسبوعيه اربع ايام في الاسبوع الغسيل
ننتقلها من منطقه نجران واضطرينا احنا
نسكن في عشير وحنا من سكان منطقه نجران
والحمد لله
توفرت نقلنا هنا الدمام وتمت الزراعه
والحمد لله تغير الحال
وصرنا الحمد لله احسن مرتاحين المواعيد في
الشهر مره
اكثر من مئه عمليه اجراها مركز امراض
وزراعه الكلى للاطفال في مستشفى الملك فهد
التخصصي بالدمام وسط ارتفاع نسبه التبرع
من الاحياء الى 90% غالبيه المتبرعين من
اهالي المرضى فيما تبقى الحاجه لحالات
التبرع مرتفعه قياسا بعدد عمليات التي
اجريها المركز قمنا بما يقارب
207 عمليه زراعه كلى تقريبا 60% منها
لاطفال ذكور نسبه
التبرع من الاحياء ولله الحمد وهي كانت
اكثر من 90% واغلبها من الاباء او الامهات
من الدمام علي اللغبي العربيه
[موسيقى]
من جده ينظم الينا استاذ طب كل الاطفال
بجامعه الملك عبد العزيز الدكتور اسامه
صفدر دكتور اسامه حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض
خليني اسالك في البدايه هل هناك حالات
شائعه مثل حاله الطفلين مفلحوا في الحل
اللي شفناهم في التقرير قبل قليل وش اساسا
اسباب اصابه الاطفال بالفشل الكلوي
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته الف شكر
يعطيكم العافيه على هذا اللقاء طبعا
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه او بشكل
عام أكل الاطفال ليست شائعه كما هي الحال
في الكبار بالنسبه اقل بكثير لكن هذه
الفئه تحتاج للتعامل مع مراكز متخصصه كل
التعاون مع الاطفال وامراضهم والتعامل مع
اوزانهم يختلف يعني عن الكبار والاسباب
كذلك تختلف في الاطفال عنها على الكبار
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا توجد
احصائيات كثيره حول شيوع المواط الاطفال
لكن في احد الدراسات هي تقريبا من بين كل
مئه الف طفل هناك 16 طفل سنويا يصاب بمرض
القصور الكلوي 16
هم يصابون به يعني يعني هم يولدون بطريقه
طبيعيه وامورهم الصحيه ممتازه وبعد ذلك
يصابون بالفشل الكلوي ولا منذ الولاده
يعني يكون معهم هالموضوع هذا سؤال ممتاز
العالميه بسبب العمل الوراثيه هم الغالبيه
منهم يولدون بهذه التشوهات او العيوب
الخلقيه عند الولاده يعني في هناك بعض
الامراض مثل تكيس الكلى مثل انسداد
المجاري البوليه مثل مرض المثانه العصبيه
حيث المثانه التي تستطيع تفريغ البول
يتجمع البول واضغط على الكلى كل هذه امراض
اغلبيتها نسميها امراض خلقيه وراثيه يولد
بها الاطفال طبعا في نسبه اقل اللي هي
الامراض المكتسبه مثل الامراض المناعيه
بسبب الامراض تؤدي الى التهابات في
شعوريات الدمويه للكلى او المتلازمات
الكلويه التي لا تستجيب عن علاج
الغالبيه العظمى زي ما تفضلت هي امراض
يولد بها الاطفال عند الاولاد طيب دكتور
عن عمليات الزراعه للاطفال ويمكن كان في
نموذج تابعنا في التقرير اللي هو مفلح وفي
ايضا
بس ابغى اتكلم بشكل بشكل عام اولا هل في
نسبه تبرع عاليه وبالتالي انت باستطاعتك
او بامكانك انه تزرع او تجري عمليه زراعه
لهؤلاء الاطفال
وهل في اعداد او تقديرات لعمليات زراعه
الكره للاطفال في السعوديه
عاديه الامير محمد ونفتخر بكل هذه الصوره
الطبيه العظيمه اكيد الدكتور يعني ما هي
حالات او او الظروف التي يمكن فيها علاج
هؤلاء الاطفال
دون اللجوء الى عمليه زراعه الكلى في اي
حالات باختصار اذا سمحت يعني الافضل بعمل
الفحوصات والاشاعات والجينات ولكن طبعا
المتقدمه فالزراعه هي الحل الافضل اذا لم
تكن هناك الزراعه فهناك يعني المحافظه على
الكلى بالحنيه بالرياضه بالتحكم بالضغط
بالابتعاد عن الاعشاب الغير معروفه
والمسكنات الضاره بالكلى في حاله طبعا
وصول الموحد المتقدمه اما زراعه او غسيل
والغسيل طبعا في غسيل طبعا هي في النهايه
تحافظ ولكن ليس بالكلى الاصليه او الكل
المزروعه ورجع اقولها وحتى الزراعه تحتاج
الى اماكن متخصصه
بين اهله يغسل في المنزل ثم يصل الصباح
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من جدان طب علينا
الاطفال بجامعه الملك عبد العزيز الدكتور
اسامه شكرا دكتور
اظهرت نتائج المسح الاحصائيه الذي اعلنت
عنه الهيئه العامه للاحصاء في السعوديه عن
ارتفاع عدد الاسر الى ثمانيه ملايين الف
اسره نصفها تقريبا من الاسره السعوديه
تفاصيل اكثر مع الزميله العنود العبدلي
كشف تقرير هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه الاخيره
عن تفاصيل اعداد ومتوسط حجم الاسر حيث بلغ
اجمالي وعددها بشكل عام
8.2 مليون اسره وبالتفصيل كما نشاهد هنا
فقد بلغ عدد الاسر السعوديه
4.2 مليون اسره اما الاسر غير السعوديه
فقد بلغ عددها اربعه ملايين عدد الاسر
مشاهدينا التي تتكون من فرد واحد في
السعوديه بلغت اثنين فاصل واحد او اثنين
فاصل واحد مليون اسره اما الاسر التي
تتكون من فردين فاكثر بلغت سته ملايين
اسره وعند الحديث مشاهدينا عن متوسط حجم
الاسره في السعوديه فقد بلغ عددها او بلغ
عدد افرادها ثلاثه فاصله سبعه لكل اسره
حيث بلغ متوسط حجم الاسر السعوديه منها
اربعه فاصل ثمانيه اما عن المتوسط حجم
الاسد غير السعوديه فقد بلغ 2.7 افرا لكل
اسره لنرى الان مشاهدينا حجم الاسر في
مختلف مناطق السعوديه فكما نرى الحدود
الشماليه بلغ حجم الاسري فيها الاعلى بين
جميع مناطق السعوديه حيث بلغ عددها 4.9
افراد لكل اسره ياتي بعد ذلك منطقه الجوف
حيث بلغ متوسط حجم الاسره فيها
4.6 افراد اتباعها منطقه نجران كما نشاهد
باربعه فاصل اربعه اما منطقه الرياض ومكه
مشاهدينا فمتوسط حجم الاسره بلغ في كل
المنطقتين ثلاثه فاصل سته افراد مع اختلاف
اعداد الاسري فيها والمنطقه الشرقيه فكما
نشاهد هنا بلغ متوسط حجم الاسره فيها
3.5 افراد لنرى الان مشاهدينا عن كثب
توزيع الاسر المعيشيه على المدن السعوديه
والتي يقصد بها فرد او مجبوقه افراد
اشتركونا في المسكن والماكل ويقيمون بنفس
المسكن وقت العد لنبدا من الرياض فقد بلغ
فيها نحو مليون وتسعمائه الف وجده بلغ
مشاهدينا عدد الاسري فيها نحو مليون
واثنين الفا اما مكه بلغ عدد الاسري فيها
مشاهدين نحو 600 الف والدمام نحو 426 الف
اما المدينه المنوره مشاهدينا فقط سجلت
حوالي
356 الف اسره وعند الحديث عن نسبه الاعاله
العمريه في السعوديه بشكل عام فقد بلغت
نسبتها
37.3 وتفصيلا كما نشاهد هنا نسبه الاعاله
للسعوديين بلغت
62% واما لغير السعودي مشاهدينا فقد بلغت
نسبه الاعاله فيها 13,2%
الرابع مستمره وفي بعد قليل
اداره المرور السعوديه تبدا غدا رصد سبع
مخالفات مؤثره في السلامه العامه
الكترونيا
حياكم الله من جديد حصلت مدينه الملك عبد
الله الاقتصاديه على ترخيص المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخاصه ما يمنحها وصولا مباشرا
الى جميع اسواق منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا وباشراف مباشر من هيئه المدن
والمناطق الاقتصاديه الخاصه هذا وتركز
المدينه على القطاعات الاقتصاديه الرئيسيه
وتصنيع السيارات والمواد الاستهلاكيه
والاغذيه والادويه والخدمات اللوجستيه
والصناعات المصاحبه لها
يبدا المرور السعوديه اعتبارا من غدا
الاحد تفعيل رصد الاليل لمجموعه من
المخالفات المؤثره في السلامه العامه حيث
تشمل المخالفات عدم التزام الشاحنات
والمعدات الثقيله بالسير في المسار الايمن
بالطريق المتعدد المسارات وعدم استخدام
الانوار اللازمه عند السير ليلا او نهارا
في
الاحوال الجويه التي تكون فيها الرؤيه غير
واضحه
كشفت هيئه التراث السعودي عن اكتشاف
وتوثيق اقدم سادس نقش عربي مبكر يقع في
جبل الحجوم بمنطقه
حمى الثقافيه في نجران وذلك ضمن اعمال
المسح التي تجريها واوضحت الهيئه ان
النقشه التذكاري لكعب ابن عمرو ابن عبد
منات الذي سجله وختمه بتاريخ تنفيذه وفقا
للتقويم النبطي يعد اضافه علميه في سجل
الكتابات العربيه المبكره في جنوب الجزيره
العربيه
قبل ختام الرابع نتوقف مع هذا الفيديو
الذي يظهر تاثر والد بتخرج ابنته في حفل
تخرجها من احدى المؤسسات التعليميه في
السعوديه نتابع
ونختم الرابعه
الجيش المصري يؤكد مقتل عنصري امن باطلاق
نار بعد اجتيازه حاجزا اسرائيليا اثناء
مطارده مهربي مخدرات
الزراعه خارجيه السعوديه وايران يلتقيان
على هامش اجتماع مجموعه بيكس في جنوب
افريقيا
السعوديه تبدا حصر اصحاب الاجور المتجاوزه
للسقف الاعلى وتعتمد عقدا حكوميا موحدا
للعمل
العربيه توثق قصه شفاء الطفلين مفلح وفي
الحال من الفشل الكلوي بعد اجراء عمليه
زراعه للكلاب
رابعا شكرا لك للمتابعه في رعايه الله
لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار قياد والتقارير الاخباريه لا
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات